[Música]
muy pronto todos los usuarios de
Facebook e Instagram tendrán que pagar
si quieren que sus cuentas estén
verificadas esta semana se ensayo el
programa metal en Australia y en Nueva
Zelanda la idea del ceo Mark Zuckerberg
es expandirlo pronto al resto del mundo
para ello cobrarán 11,99 dólares
mensuales a quienes verifiquen sus
cuentas en la web y 14,99 a quienes lo
hagan a través de la aplicación móvil a
cambio estas personas recibirán la placa
de que sus cuentas están verificadas y
también tendrán mayor seguridad
cibernética al menos así lo dice la
empresa meta adicionalmente aparecerán
más fácilmente en las búsquedas y
contarán con un acceso privilegiado al
servicio de ayuda al cliente para hablar
de este tema Primero quiero saludar a
nuestra periodista de especializada en
economía Daniela Blandón quien está aquí
en nuestros estudios Daniela Gracias por
volver bueno María Clara aquí estaremos
entonces preguntandole a nuestra
invitada y hablando de la invitada le
quiero dar una especial bienvenida
porque nos acompaña desde Buenos Aires
Claudia alderete especialista en
transformación digital Claudia Buenos
días para usted y gracias quiero
comenzar con la primera pregunta porque
meta perdió 600 mil millones de dólares
en 2022 y despidió al 13% de su personal
este sistema de pago por verificación
Usted cree que es un intento por paliar
la crisis económica de la compañía o lo
que busca es mayor seguridad como lo
Afirma zucker Buenos días María Teresa
Daniela gracias por la invitación creo
que el sistema de verificación tiene que
ver con una diversificación del negocio
meta hasta el momento su principal
fuente de ingresos es la publicidad y
hay varias compañías que a través de los
problemas de seguridad que ha tenido
Facebook en el último tiempo y las
controversias acerca del manejo y la
seguridad de los datos han parado
campañas por completo dentro de Facebook
con lo cual Este modelo de suscripción
podría ser una nueva fuente de ingresos
que permita recuperar un poco ese
revenue que la compañía ha perdido de
manera tan catastrófica en los últimos
meses Claudia en la práctica hoy en día
quienes pueden tener ese esa
verificación azul y quienes la van a
poder tener porque también hay muchas
dudas sobre qué tan seguro puede hacer
esto y que cualquier persona pueda
simplemente copagar 15 dólares al mes ya
tener su cuenta verificada y puede ser
fácilmente una persona que no sea la que
está ahí en la foto por ejemplo hay un
un sistema de seguridad que en este
proceso de verificación Facebook y
Instagram te lo piden que tienen que ver
con subir una foto de tu carnet de
identidad y tienen que coincidir tu
nombre y apellido con el nombre y
apellido que tenés dentro de la
plataforma Recuerden que este tipo de
verificación por ahora es solamente para
individuos no para compañías ni para
empresas ni para marcas Entonces ese
sistema de poder subir una foto de tu
carnet de identidad es la manera de
asegurarse de que seas una persona real
puede fallar Sin lugar a dudas pero es
una de las formas de tratar de que este
sistema de verificación funcione y sea
más seguro para los usuarios de Facebook
pero del otro lado también existe otro
riesgo en cuanto a la información y es
qué tan seguro es darle a Facebook e
Instagram una fotografía de los
documentos de identidad como usted lo
decía sobre todo teniendo en cuenta la
filtración de datos personales que ya ha
comprometido a Facebook antes por
supuesto sin lugar a dudas es uno de los
grandes isus porque Lamentablemente
Facebook no ha demostrado ser sólido en
términos de los manejos de datos
privados de sus usuarios en el último
tiempo con varios escándalos en los que
estuve involucrados y por los que Mark
zu tuvo que ir a responderse entre al
congreso de Estados Unidos pero en ese
sentido ese importante tener en cuenta
que
la verificación no es obligatoria es
completamente voluntaria y en ese en ese
sentido
la seguridad se supone que va a estar un
poco más robusta y que Facebook ha
aprendido o esperamos que haya aprendido
la lección de Cómo manejar los datos de
sus usuarios y tenga un buen uso de este
de esta información tan sensible que
está pidiendo a los usuarios para
verificar
Claudia que podemos esperar entonces
porque Facebook no es la única Twitter
ya lo hizo hay varias redes sociales que
ya han incursionado en esto del cobro
por verificación o el cobro por
suscripción vamos a llegar al momento en
el que ya no va a ser gratis para los
usuarios tener acceso a estas redes
sociales y también porque como se está
moviendo el tema de la de la publicidad
porque finalmente lo que los lleva a
cobrar
hay diferentes situaciones dependiendo
de la plataforma sin lugar a dudas las
plataformas no van a ir a un modelo
totalmente pago para poder usarlos sino
que estos modelos de suscripción van a
dar a quienes los elijan ciertos
privilegios por sobre aquellos que no
los elijan entonces en algún momento tal
vez Vos como usuario tomes la decisión
de tener esta este proceso de
verificación esta suscripción para
llamarlo correctamente porque te
interesan algunas de las funcionalidades
que te que te brinda por ejemplo Twitter
está probando una verificación para los
negocios lo cual sería muy útil y
seguramente sería una fuente de revenue
bastante interesante para una plataforma
que ha luchado durante muchos años para
tener
balances positivos en comparación por
ejemplo con Facebook y con Instagram No
creo que se vaya un modelo totalmente
cerrado y de y de pago porque tampoco le
conviene a las plataformas no tener
usuarios volumen de usuario finalmente
eso es lo que hace que la publicidad sea
atractiva tener volumen de usuarios que
puedan verla de manera tal que un modelo
completamente cerrado iría en contra de
ese revenue que se da por publicidad así
que dudo mucho que vayamos a un modelo
completamente cerrado o completamente
pago para poder usar estas herramientas
que hasta hace muy poquito eran
completamente gratuitas y otro de los
reveses de este sistema de verificación
además de los que usted nos cuenta
Claudia lo vivió precisamente Twitter el
año pasado que tuvo que retirar su pago
de verificación por la cantidad de
cuentas falsas que se estaban
verificando Puede ocurrir lo mismo con
Facebook e Instagram
podría ocurrir lo mismo un poco esta
idea de poder tener que subir tu foto de
tu carnet de identidad podría ser un
stopper una forma de evitar lo que pasó
con Twitter Pero la verdad es que no hay
posibilidades de entender Si los
controles que va a ser Facebook para los
procesos de verificación van a poder
evitar lo que pasó con Twitter el año
pasado no no es posible adelantarnos a
eso Gracias Claudia por acompañarnos
aquí en France 24 Gracias a ustedes por
la invitación que tengan buen día Y
gracias También a nuestra periodista
Daniela Blandón a ustedes los invitamos
a que sigan con nosotros Porque en
minutos volvemos con más noticias
internacionales
[Música]